Senator Rand Paul who said there's no
he's he's gonna vote for her I said this
in an op-ed there's no question that
during her career Haspel participated in
and helped develop the program that our
own government has labeled torture
further multiple accounts have discussed
her involvement in destroying video
documentation of the torture program
he says direct participation in the
program itself would be disqualifying
enough for me but appointing someone who
also helped push for destroying evidence
of that program to run one of the most
powerful organizations in the world
should not be acceptable to Congress Ben
well this seems to me a dramatic miss
Reed I mean if you're going to rule out
anyone who is working at the CIA at the
time this was going down and who refused
to and who was going along with any
order that happened about waterboarding
the waterboarding program was run by
members of Congress Democrats and
Republicans both approved it at the time
people in the CIA across the board were
involved in this program so if you're
trying to spot somebody who's working at
the CIA at the time who forcibly opposed
it and refused to participate in the
waterboarding program that's gonna be a
real short list the question now is this
is against the law she says that she
recognizes it's against the law I see no
evidence to suggest that she's going to
buck the law and randomly start go
waterboarding people so I'm wondering
what exactly the objection to Haspel
particularly is when she obeyed the law
at the time and she'll presumably
continue to obey the law now that the
law has changed well we have a letter
that was signed by a number of
intelligence agency past and present key
leaders saying this she will speak truth
to power
offering unbiased intelligence to policy
makers no matter how difficult the
situation
it's truly telling that a broad spectrum
of national security leaders from both
Republican and Democratic
administrations have voiced unequivocal
support for her nomination now signers
to that letter included former CIA
director John Brennan and former
Director of National Intelligence James
clapper of course Richard both of them
in the Obama administration they say
she's got our seal of approval listen
they couldn't continue to say that but
it doesn't it doesn't take away from the
fact that she was involved in torture
and I think that's the larger point here
and this side the argument that's being
made that well just hurts to her Pete
the people above her told her to do it
so she did it
doesn't take away from the fact that she
actually engaged in torture on top of
running one of these black sites where
the torture was taking place here's what
we know the the army the army manual
says that torture is actually
ineffective way to get intelligence
because most of the time the
interpersonal Terry
ends up lying anyway so they could stop
the pain that's happening to them but
that's beyond the point here's what we
also know is that we as Americans have
never subscribed to torture from the
beginning of this country to today we
believe we're not this is not how we
live our lives this is not the city upon
the hill that we although were trying to
be so by appointing her and voting her
to be the head of the CIA you are
codifying torture as part of the agency
and that's what matters not if she has
rebuked that and said that she's not
going to take part in it anymore I mean
the excerpt that we have in that Kristen
reported on she actually says in no way
is she going to restart that torture
program and to the point of whether it
was any good I mean the Obama Justice
Department and two federal judges
actually ruled that there was
life-saving intelligence that was
gathered by these black sites under the
CIA that's in the past though been isn't
enough of an assurance for you that she
says not gonna restart it should she
become CIA director I mean it is for me
because again should be violating the
law if she did not write if she suddenly
started disobeying and waterboarding
people at random then she would be in
violation of the law I'm really weirded
out by this sort of conflation between
two issues one is is waterboarding bad
and two is is anyone who participated in
waterboarding therefore bad these are
not the same issue even if you believe
that waterboarding was bad which i think
is arguable considering again that
everybody Democrat and Republican at the
time virtually everyone approved it and
it did end with actionable intelligence
from people like Khalid Sheikh Mohammed
we didn't put that aside even if
assuming you that waterboarding is is a
terrible horrible thing
the real question now is is anyone who
participated in that when it was the law
of the land now barred from holding a
higher office and if that's the case
then pretty much everybody at the CIA
who knew about this program everybody in
Congress who know about this program
everyone is barred from holding office
including a budget I'm here